[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland eurem täglichen truecrime
Podcast von Bild bei mir im Studio ist
mein Kollege Stefan Netzeband hallo
Stefan hallo Merkel und mit mir sitzt
hier der Mann mit der verbrecherisch
guten Stimme Mirko Kasimir liebe Zuhörer
statistisch gesehen werden ja die
meisten Morde immer noch von Männern
begangen weshalb wir uns hier heute in
trauter Männerrunde dazu entschieden
haben den beeindruckenden Fall einer
Mörderin aus den USA zu schildern genau
das also eine Form der
Gleichberechtigung dass wir quasi auch
eine Frau in diese Runde holen spaß
beiseite wie erzählen heute von Sharon
kinny einer zierlichen Hausfrau aus dem
Suli die einige ich sag mal
bemerkenswerte Punkte in ihrem
Lebenslauf vorweisen kann oh ja zum
Beispiel stand sie sage und schreibe
noch mal wegen Mordes vor Gericht das
musst du erstmal schaffen und sie hält
einen traurigen Rekord auf sie ist der
längste laufende Haftbefehl in der
Geschichte von kernses City Missouri
ausgestellt einer der am längsten
laufenden in der gesamten Geschichte der
USA seit gut 60 Jahren ist sie auf der
Flucht Sharon kinny ist oder wäre man
weiß es ja nicht heute 83 Jahre alt gut
möglich dass sie inzwischen den
ultimativen Zufluchtsort vor dem Gesetz
gefunden hat nämlich das Grab das heute
wurde sie auf jeden Fall nicht gefunden
19 märz 1960 eine Stadt in Missouri mit
dem schönen Namen in die Pendants
Unabhängigkeit ein Haus im typischen
Range Stil in einer dieser typischen
Vorstädte einer mittelgroßen
amerikanischen Stadt wie man sie aus
zahlreichen TV-Serien oder Filmen kennt
es ist später Nachmittag Sharon kinny
Hausfrau und Mutter ist im Haus
beschäftigt Tochter Dehner süße
zweieinhalb Jahre alt spielt mit ihrem
Vater James Kenny ist Elektroingenieur
und arbeitet meistens nachts auch heute
hat er nach einer langen Schicht den
ganzen Tag verschlafen und die Kleine
ist bei ihm im Schlafzimmer ein ganz
normaler Nachmittag bis der Schussfeld
Sharon lässt alles fallen und stürmt ins
Schlafzimmer und dort
fällt ein Stein vom Herzen Denner sitzt
auf dem Bett und schaut ihre Mutter an
gott sei dank ihrer Tochter ist nichts
passiert im selben Augenblick sieht sie
das schwarze Ding in Danas Händen eine
Pistole und dann sieht sie James neben
dem Bett auf dem Boden blut läuft aus
einer Wunde am Hinterkopf das ist
zumindest die Geschichte die sie der
Polizei erzählt dass ihre
zweieinhalbjährige Tochter ihren Ehemann
erschossen hat genau und man glaubt ihr
es klingt plausibel sowohl Sharon als
auch verschiedene Bekannte und Nachbarn
geben an dass James kinni seine Tochter
gelegentlich mit seiner Waffe spielen
ließ alter das ist komplett verrückt
aber okay in einer Gesellschaft in der
Waffen im Haus total normal sind ja
absolut genug dass dort jeder Waffen
besitzen kann aber Kleinkinder damit
spielen zu lassen ist auch in den USA
nichts unbedingt das was man gut
parenting nennt
aber niemand nahm an dem nicht so ganz
altersgerechten Spielzeug von Dana
Anstoß zumindest nicht vor dem tödlichen
Schuss an der Waffe werden keine
Fingerabdrücke gefunden weil sie
offenbar gerade eingeölt worden war und
die Polizei für dein Experiment durch
das zeigt dass Derna stark genug ist um
den Abzug der Waffe ihres Vaters zu
betätigen
James Kinn ist tot wird als
versehentlicher Totschlag zu den Akten
gelegt Deutschland hätte man
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen genauer
nachgeforscht aber so traurig das ist in
den USA ist man dergleichen beinahe
gewöhnt ich habe hier eine Statistik von
2017 rausgesucht in dem Jahr wurden 383
Unfälle registriert bei denen Kinder mit
Schusswaffen antiert haben mehr als 186
Menschen starben dabei das ist wirklich
krass ja absolut ich begreife einfach
nicht dass die Leute ernsthaft glauben
können das ist zur Sicherheit beiträgt
wenn das ganze Land unter Waffen steht
dafür gibt es ja auch der Spruch der der
Waffenlobby gern zitiert ganz don't kill
people people kill people ja Waffen
töten keine Menschen töten Menschen das
ist im Grundsatz zwar richtig aber
natürlich eine sehr vereinfachte
Darstellung der Tatsachen ich finde an
der hohen Zahl an Gewalttaten in den USA
zeigt sich deutlich was der freie Zugang
zu Waffen anrichtet und das ist auf
jeden Fall einer staatlichen Regulierung
Bedarf auf jeden Fall aber für mich ist
das eher ein Argument dafür den Menschen
keine Waffen zu geben und schon gar
nicht zweieinhalbjährigen ich denke
darauf können wir uns alle einigen aber
man muss wohl davon ausgehen dass James
kinni gar nicht von seiner Tochter
erschossen wurde sondern von seiner
Ehefrau Mirko erzähl uns mal von Sharon
ja
Sharon Elizabeth Hall wird am 30
November 1939 in independence geboren
als Teenager kommt ihr der Name ihres
Geburtsortes independence Unabhängigkeit
wie hohen vor sie will unabhängig sein
sie will Weg raus aus dieser tief
religiösen Provinz statt raus in die
große weite Welt und der beste Weg dazu
scheint ihr eine Heirat zu sein es wird
berichtet dass Sie gezielt nach einem
Mann sucht der sie da rausholen kann mit
16 lernt sie den 22-Jährigen James kinny
kennen und er scheint genau der Richtige
zu sein immerhin geht er aufs College
aus ihm wird einmal etwas werden dabei
stammt James aus einer Familie von
tiefgläubigen Mormonen Angehörige der
Kirche Jesu Christi der Heiligen der
Letzten Tage auch das College dass er
besucht wird von dieser Kirche bezahlt
und ich weiß nicht für mich klingt diese
Beziehung jetzt nicht nach einem Ticket
in die große weite Welt ganz ehrlich
gesagt na ist ja auch nicht
1956 heiraten die beiden auf dem
Trauschein steht fälschlich dass Sharon
schon 18 Jahre alt sei
Sharon tritt der Kirche Jesu Christi der
Heiligen der Letzten Tage bei um auch
die kirchliche Trauung vollziehen zu
können das Paar zieht nach Provo in Utah
na ja das ist jetzt auch nicht gerade
New York Paris oder Mailand aber
immerhin allerdings bleiben sie da nicht
lange im Herbst desselben Jahres kehren
sie nach independence zurück und mieten
ein Haus neben dem von James Eltern
nichts da mit großer Freiheit zurück in
der Heimatstadt und die Schwiegermutter
zur Nachbarin furchtbar ehrlich ja das
muss wirklich bitter für sie gewesen
sein wenigstens ziehen sie nach einer
Weile in ein anderes Haus im Herbst 1957
wird Tochter Denner geboren Sharon
versucht ein bisschen Glanz in ihren
Alltag als Hausfrau zu bringen indem sie
viel zu viel Geld ausgibt und sich mit
schönen Dingen um
und irgendwann auch mit schönen Männern
naja also zumindest mit Männern denn
Fotos liegen uns hier keine vor während
James also Nachtschichten durch rockt
vertreibt sie sich die Nächte auf eine
sagen wir einfach andere Weise als Troy
das zweite Kind von Sharon und James zur
Welt kommt hat Sharon eine regelmäßige
Affäre mit John Baldis einem alten
Schulfreund ihr Mann denkt schließlich
über eine Scheidung nach er verdächtigt
sie zurecht der Untreue und er hat wegen
ihres verschwenderischen Lebensstils
Schulden doch seine frommen Eltern reden
ihm diesen Gedanken aus Sharon so wird
berichtet hätte die Scheidung gern
angenommen wenn sie das Haus das
Sorgerecht und 1000 Dollar Unterhalt im
Monat bekommen hätte da denkt sie wohl
längst auch über alternative Wege sag
ich mal so aus der Ehe nach ich sag mal
so bis dass der Tod euch scheidet
vielleicht ihr Liebhaber paul ist sagt
später aus dass sie 1000 Dollar geboten
habe um James zu töten oder jemanden zu
finden der das tut nach James Kennys Tod
bei einem wie es scheint tragischen
Unfall streicht Sharon eine
Lebensversicherung in Höhe von 29.000
ein das entspreche heute einem Wert von
beinahe einer Viertelmillion Dollar
ziemlich genau einen Monat nach dem
tödlichen Schuss kauft sich die Witwe
von dem Geld einen Ford Thunderbird die
lässt nichts anbrennen fort Thunderbird
kennt ihr oder der klassische
amerikanische Sportwagen filmreif immer
bekannt aus Goldfinger American Graffiti
und Vellmar und Louis viel Chrom und
fettes Boiler die Modelle der 50er und
65er Jahre die sehen aus wie der Blech
gewordene amerikanische Traum nicht die
übliche witwenschleuder würde ich sagen
ah ganz sicher nicht ähm witwenschleuder
das Wort kann ich noch gar nicht ich
auch nicht
weiß auch nicht wo das jetzt hergekommen
ist und was ich nicht erwähnt habe die
haben sicherlich auch unsinnig viel
verbraucht diese Autos aber wichtiger
als der Wagen selbst ist der
Autoverkäufer bei dem sie ihn am 18
April 1960 kauft Walter Jones die beiden
beginnen kurz darauf eine Affäre und
sharen sieht ihn als Kandidaten für eine
zweite Ehe nur leider ist Walter Jones
schon mit Patricia Jones verheiratet die
Ehe kriselt aber Walter macht keine
Anstalten patischer zu verlassen also
setzte ihm die Pistole auf die Brust
sozusagen sie nämlich Sharon sie sagt
ihm dass sie schwanger von ihm sei und
er sich scheiden lassen müsste geradezu
aber Jones lehnt ab und beendet
stattdessen die Affäre Sharon Kenny ist
nicht bereit das zu akzeptieren sie ruft
Walters Frau Patricia Jones in deren
Büro an und behauptet Walter habe eine
Affäre mit ihrer Schwester
nach Feierabend treffen sich die beiden
Frauen um die Angelegenheit weiter zu
besprechen laut Sharons Aussage fährt
Sie Patricia später heim und setzt sie
in der Nähe ihres Wohnhauses ab doch
dort kommt sie nie an am nächsten Tag
meldet Walter Jones seine Frau als
vermisst nach wenigen Stunden findet er
sie selbst in einem abgelegenen Gebiet
das etwa eine Meile außerhalb von den
dependence liegt und nicht überraschend
natürlicher Walters ist tot zu diesem
Zeitpunkt
[Musik]
okay aber wie konnte er sie so schnell
finden Walter Jones muss zu diesem
Zeitpunkt schon vermutet haben dass
Sharon kinny etwas mit dem Verschwinden
zu tun hat und ihr ehemaliger Geliebter
John boulders gibt ihm einen Tipp für
die Suche einen stillen abgelegenen Ort
den Sharon und er oft für ihre
heimlichen Treffen genutzt haben
Patricia Jones wurde mit vier Schüssen
ermordet mindestens einer der Schüsse
wurde aus unmittelbarer Nähe abgegeben
obwohl weder Tatwaffe noch andere
handfeste Beweise gefunden werden ist
sich die Polizei bald sicher dass Sharon
Kini die Täterin ist am 31 Mai 1960 am
Tag der Beerdigung von Patricia Jones
wird Sharon kinny verhaftet es dauert
mehr als ein Jahr bis der erste
Mordprozess gegen Sharon beginnt immer
wieder ist sie auf Kaution draußen immer
wieder wird auch der Termin verschoben
sie ist auch tatsächlich schwanger von
Walter und bringt am 16 Januar 19 1961
eine weitere Tochter zur Welt aber dann
im Juni desselben Jahres steht sie
endlich wegen Mordes vor Gericht zum
ersten Mal und um den jetzt folgenden
gerichtsmarathon ein bisschen abzukürzen
sie wird freigesprochen die Jury hält
die Beweise nicht verschlüssig da sind
einfach zu viele fehlende Glieder in der
Beweiskette und zumindest ein
Jurymitglied scheint unangemessen
angetan von der Angeklagten zu sein nach
der Verhandlung bietet er sie um ein
Autogramm heiliger Stroh sagt was für
eine juristische Meisterleistung nicht
die Berichterstattung hat sie zu einer
Art Promi gemacht sieht man ja an diesen
Typen und das scheint nicht zu ihrem
Nachteil gewesen zu sein ich bin ein
Star holt mich hier raus aus dem
Gefängnis wenn mir dieser kleine Platte
Gag erlaubt ist nach dem Tod von
Patricia Jones mag niemand mehr so
richtig an die Geschichte von der
schießwütigen Tochter glauben im Januar
steht Sharon Kinney wegen Mordes an
ihrem Ehemann James Kenny vor Gericht
und man muss sagen anfangs sieht es
sogar gut für sie aus
Hauptbelastungszeuge ist ihr Ex-Lover
boldis der ja behauptete dass sie ihm
1000 Dollar geboten hätte wenn er ihren
Mann tötet jetzt schränkt er die Aussage
ein das sei doch nur ein Scherz gewesen
lässt er das erstaunte Gericht wissen
seine Glaubwürdigkeit ist damit dahin
die Verteidigung kann außerdem viele
Indizien Beweise anfechten und Zeugen
vorweisen die erzählen sie hätten Dana
regelmäßig mit Waffen spielen sehen
doch es nutzt nichts am 11 Januar 1962
wird Sharon wegen Mordes zu lebenslanger
Haft verurteilt und tritt ihre
Haftstrafe an und wenn sie nicht
gestorben ist dann sitzt sie noch immer
leider nein denkste im März 63 wird das
Urteil aufgrund zahlreicher
Verfahrensfehler aufgehoben der Fall
muss neu verhandelt werden Sharon kommt
gegen Kaution auf freien Fuß und wartet
auf den Beginn des neuen Prozesses nach
unserer Zählweise Mordprozess Nummer 3
ja wie schon gesagt wir kürzen das hier
ein bisschen ab auch dieser Versuch
scheitert der Grund Gefangenheit eines
Staatsanwaltes
1964 dann der nächste Anlauf doch auch
hier geht es nicht weiter da sich die
Jury nicht auf ihre Schuld oder
unschuldigen kann der vierte Prozess
wegen des Mordes an ihrem Ehemann also
der fünfte Mordprozess gegen sie
überhaupt wird auf oktober 1964
festgelegt doch zu diesem Prozess kommt
es nie
Sharon ist nämlich zwischen den
Prozessen gegen Kaution auf freiem Fuß
und jetzt hat sie wohl endgültig die
Faxen dicke und macht sich aus dem Staub
mit einem Liebhaber natürlich wir haben
sie jetzt ja auch schon ein bisschen
kennengelernt dem Rest der
Lebensversicherung ihres Mannes und ohne
die Kinder die lässt sie nämlich bei
deren Stiefvater aber schon im Sommer
1965 steht sie wieder wegen Mordes vor
Gericht allerdings in Mexiko und für
einen neuen Mord sie kann es nicht
lassen scheint mir ihr Lover und sie
haben sich also nach Mexiko abgesetzt
geben sich als Ehepaar aus und leben in
einem Hotel am 18 September lernt sie in
einer Bar Francisco Paradis ordonis
kennen einen in Mexiko geborenen
amerikanischen Staatsbürger und dann
jetzt begleitet sie auf das Hotelzimmer
ihr Liebhaber ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt
unterwegs angeblich habe er ihr dort
Fotos zeigen wollen naja im Hotel aber
macht er ihr schnell sexuelle avensen so
schildert es Sharon später der Polizei
sie zieht eine Waffe um sich vor seiner
Vergewaltigung zu retten und nur um ihn
zu erschrecken wie sie behauptet
unglücklicherweise lösen sich Schüsse
treffen seine Brust und töten ihn ein
Hotelangestellter hört die Schüsse
betritt das Hotelzimmer sofort schießt
Sharon auf ihn und trifft ihn an der
Schulter doch der Mann kann verletzt
fliehen und beweist Geistes Gegenwart
indem man sie einschließt und die
Polizei ruft die Ermittler glauben nicht
dass sie Notwehr gehandelt hat sie gehen
von einem geplanten Raub der zu einem
Raubmord wurde aus
für eine unbescholtene Touristin hat sie
einfach zu viele Patronen und Waffen bei
sich drei Pistolen insgesamt dann ist da
noch die Kleinigkeit ihrer illegalen
Einreise und der in den USA anstehende
Haftbefehl und als ich auch noch
herausstellte dass eine der Waffen die
selbe Waffe ist mit der vier Jahre zuvor
Patricia Jones erschossen wurde
zweifelt niemand mehr an ihrer Schuld
im Sommer 1965 steht sie erneut wegen
mau des vor Gericht und diesmal beim
fünften Versuch wird sie endlich wegen
Mordes rechtmäßig verurteilt
doch ich muss nur leider sagen von wegen
das ist natürlich immer noch nicht das
Ende der Geschichte sie bekommt 13 Jahre
aufgebrummt die Medien aber feiern sie
und geben ihr den Spitznamen la
pistolera die Revolverheldin und dann
eines Nachts im Jahr
1969 mein Geburtstag übrigens
verschwindet sie spurlos aus ihrer
Gefängniszelle und warten immer mehr
gesehen naja sie fliegt nach Kuba und
beginnt dort eine Affäre mit Fidel
Castro bitte was steht nicht in den
Unterlagen was in meinen eigentlich auch
nicht aber ich habe vorhin mal zum Spaß
Chat GPT gebeten mir die Geschichte von
Sharon kinny zu erzählen du meinst die
diese diese künstliche Jetski genau und
die hat mir diese Geschichte mit viele
Castro aufgetischt und ich habe dann
natürlich gleich angefangen nach Belegen
dafür zu suchen aber im ganzen Internet
wirst du nichts dazu finden also
habe ich den Chatbot gefragt ob er mir
die Quelle nennen kann und ja da hat er
sich nur umständlich und ausführlich
entschuldigt dass er sich geirrt habe
und Sharon nie auf Kuba oder mit Fidel
gesehen wurde und dann hat er mir eine
andere Story aufgetischt nach der sie
kurz nach der Flucht eine weitere Frau
ermordet habe gefasst worden sei und nun
seit 1970 in Missouri im Knast sitzt das
ist doch völliger Unsinn ja als ich noch
mal nachgefragt habe hat er sich wieder
entschuldigt ich musste drei oder vier
mal nachfragen bevor er mir die richtige
Geschichte erzählt hat aber die kannte
ich natürlich schon wer denkt sich denn
bitte auch schon solche Räuberpistolen
aus also ich finde das auch krass
wenigstens gibt diese Software dann ja
zu dass das Quatsch war diese erzählt
hat aber auch ja nur wenn man nachfragt
also gut also was die
entschuldigungskultur angeht meinetwegen
ein Punkt für Chat gbt aber ansonsten na
ich bin jedenfalls froh dass wir Dich
haben und du aufpasst dass wir hier
keinen Quatsch erzählen ganze
überflüssig scheinen Menschen halt doch
noch nicht zu sein aber kurz nochmal zu
Sharon Kinney sie wurde tatsächlich seit
ihrer Flucht nicht mehr gesehen es gibt
Gerüchte dass sie sich nach Guatemala
abgesetzt hat andere behaupten die
Familie ihres letzten Opfers habe sie
aus dem Knast holen lassen um Rache zu
nehmen aber all das bleibt Spekulation
und ist ungefähr so verlässlich wie die
Antwort eines sehr fantasievollen
Chatbots und so enden wir wieder mal mit
einem Rätsel aber trotzdem was für eine
Story auf jeden Fall liebe Zuhörer
vielen Dank dass ihr dabei wart für die
Geschichte von lapisolera haben wir auf
Material von Orwells interesting.com der
englischsprachigen Wikipedia des stern
und ansonsten kommt zurückgegriffen wir
hoffen es hat euch gefallen und ihr seid
bald wieder dabei bei Tatort Deutschland
bis bald dann euer Stefan und einer
Nacht